[Music]
not everything
is as it seems
when i was 15 years old i starred in the
mcdonald's commission
you see up until this day i loved mackie
bees
but what i was made to eat was not the
burger i was used to
oh no this was made evident by the
director putting a split bucket on the
floor beside me
and saying do not swallow when i call
cut spit
it out and when biting into it cutting
my mouth and the toothpicks holding the
burger together was
the least of my worries it was the
resin-based garnish and fake burger
patty that really got good
i've never been able to eat mcdonald's
ever since
okay except at one time but that's
besides the point
15 years later and i'm on a mission to
find out if what we see on our menus
on our billboards and our tv screens are
fake and made with toxic products in
order to look good
[Music]
magician artists when you see shots in
tv commercials where the food looks
really really good
that's what bianca does she styles food
and she's worked with many international
brands such as
food network coca-cola pizza hut and kfc
so what are we gonna do is we're gonna
go to a bunch of international fast food
restaurants
we're going to look at the menus we're
going to look at the ads and we're going
to compare the food that arrives
to the food that's being advertised to
us i get into a lot of trouble
for those sorts of things people order
the food and it
doesn't quite look like the picture are
you allowed to say that
sure
i legitimately couldn't find a place to
speak about the sponsor of this video
because this is all about false
advertising which is polar opposite
to my good friends and long-term support
structure epidemic sound
which is the only real option when it
comes to sourcing sound and music for
your videos
i've partnered up with them to create
this educational series
about how to make rad engaging content
ethically
and in the most authentic way i'll talk
more about epidemic sound a little later
all right you ready for item number one
yeah i'm excited
[Applause]
it's saucy and crispy and the patty
looks all juicy and bbq basted the
cheese is all melty
wow damn it looks like someone said
goodbye
to it looks like it's been satin
advertising versus reality
if the advert is 10 out of 10 what is
this uh like a
three a three three there we have it
three out of ten
so next we have
[Applause]
scrumptious scrumptious fluffy chocolate
chip
delicious flapjack pancake stuff
should look something like this
[Music]
what i like about it is that there are
lots of chocolate chips and there's nice
thickness on the
flapjacks i give this like a five okay
pretty good
five out of ten not bad introducing
[Applause]
the cheesy pepperoni pizza hut
pizza should look like this
[Music]
wow like is there like any cheese
happening between these slices
[Music]
okay i'll go for a one out of ten okay
bianca
you like a mega pro so you telling me
that you can take
those shitty looking foods and make them
look beautiful
absolutely to my knowledge based on
tick-tock trends
and youtube i've seen that food stylists
apparently
are using highly toxic unedible very
unethical methods in order to make food
look good
so that consumers like myself
eat them we are going to remake this
food with
these unethical products okay for now
okay we have got
some moto oil shaving cream we have the
gorilla
wood glue to be malted cheese this is
completely gross and unnecessary and i
don't really see the point of this i
don't know how this would help make
the food look good we're going to put it
to the test we're going to see if this
stuff
makes food look better or if we can
actually do it
the right ethical way
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
this is a really impressive job looks
really edible
thanks dan to make it super believable
we're gonna need a character to eat it
[Music]
uh
[Music]
ah
that was shocking that was disgusting
that was really bad i still actually
have no idea why you
did that i'm weird yeah well i can
actually make the food
look as good as it tastes and tastes as
good as it looks
okay well why didn't you tell me that in
the beginning
all right
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do you mind if i have a nap will you do
this go for it
i'm not even lying i feel like i'm going
to be no hope
you're not going to be of any health
because i won't let you touch anything
get out of my kitchen
thanks for helping me shuffle though
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh wow and you didn't use any poison
no like the last time you made me eat it
twice and it was a bit less
that's good okay cool yeah all right
we're gonna start with this
yep
that's really good actually
hmm oh [ __ ] mouth yeah
[Laughter]
it was the pizza had dough from earlier
so it's been sitting all day
[ __ ] okay pretend it's
[Music]
[Music]
it i feel like this proves that one can
create ethical advertising
it's important for for people to
understand them to know that we don't
have to waste food
in order to advertise it before i start
this out i just want to tell you some
exciting news about the sponsor of this
video
epidemic sound firstly they've just
added 50
more sfx to their library going from 60
000 available sounds
to over 90 000 and secondly we've put a
sound album together
with all the kitchen and cooking
recordings from this video for you to
use in your authentic food commercials
cooking shows or vlogs all the real
diegetics available for you to download
epidemic sound is a great support
structure for me so if you support me go
over to the link in the description and
support them too
if you liked this week's video please
give it a thumbs up let me know what you
thought let us know what you thought in
the comments below
and subscribe other than that don't
forget you're awesome
and i'll see you next week
[Music]
you